la prouesse homologué à birmingham par
une jeunesse hautement sportive qui
avait réussi à comprimer 17 étudiants
dans une cabine téléphonique a déclenché
chez les jeunes du monde entier
un nouveau jeu
paris n'est naturellement pas rester à
la traîne ajoutant à ce jeu la règle du
départ aussi plaît
[Musique]
cette génération aime le contact des
pieds à la tête
le mettrons serait son idéal
[Musique]
même aux instants où la solitude et cher
ils ne conçoivent cette chaire solitude
qu'ensemble
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
27 sur une deux chevaux on pourrait
resservir le très vieux mode un homme
d'esprit qui devant cette cohue aurait
évoqué la liberté de la presse
[Musique]